みなさん、こんにちは。
このビデオの皆さん、こんにちは。
新しい2016 MacBook Proでの私の経験についてお話ししたいと
思います。具体的には
、
昨年4月に作成したハッキントッシュと比較対照します
。このビデオがすでにどこに向かっているのかわかります
。 このビデオは
私の通常の日本のコンテンツからの大きな逸脱のように見えるかもしれません
が、2016年から
の私の最初のビデオ
はまた
、ハイレビューからの皮肉な英語の技術
レビューであり、これは次の
旗艦であるため、ある意味でそれは私のルーツに戻ります キラーがフォニックスに挨拶
35z
[音楽]
2012MacBook Proに欠陥のあるグラフィック
カードがあるので、代わりにハッキントッシュを構築することにしました。
最高級のMacBookPro私の
オプションは何ですか？いくつかのmkbhdビデオ
がTony Macフォーラムの周りに
約1
週間潜んでいたので、ハッキントッシュで結論を出しました。iMacより
もはるかに強力なマシンを構築できました。
Netflixやブラザーなどのプレミアムストリーミングサービスのヘッドルームを増やすことができる価格の何分の1かで
、思い切ってこの
マシンを最初に構築しました。
前述のように、私は主にビデオを編集するためにマシンを使用
します。 私はYouTubeでコメディー動画を作ろうとし
ましたが、パトレオンで日本語を教えています。これは本当の
仕事のお母さんなので、主にスクリプト動画に使用してい
ます。動画を編集します。動画をエクスポートします。動画を
視聴します。YouTubeもキラ映画
は音楽を聴きます。
私の月収の約半分
は私が作ったビデオから来ている
のでプロのユーチューブですが、実際には私は大丈夫ですので
、ハッキントッシュについて話しましょう人々が望むものに関しては
非常に多様であると言っても過言ではありませ
ん
YouTubeのコメディーハックであるコンピューターでは、
見栄えのする強力なマシンが欲しかったのです。なぜなら
、無駄な社会のほとんどのメンバーと同じように
、光沢のあるコンピューターケースを持っていると
どういうわけか私の創造的な努力を助けて
くれます具体的には
、これらの
強化ガラスパネルの不透明度と
、Intel 6700K16ギガバイトのCorsairVengeanceAMDr9を選んだジョークを構築する能力との間に直接的な相関関係があると思い込んでいます
スピーディーなSamsung950Proで390
をクライオリグh7で冷却
そこで、
El Capitanをインストールして、
公式の20 Meccaガイドを使用するか、少なくともYouTube
にアップロードしたビデオを泣いてみました。このビデオでは
、
完成したhackintoshビルドが実際に
はコンピューターの偽物であり、このショットには
インターネットサウンドが機能していませんでした。 または
bluetoothこれらすべての機能を動作させるのに約1週間かかった
ので、これ
により、ハッキン
トッシュのセットアップの1つ、または私がフォードと呼んでいるものを指摘することができます。
悲惨な川の中で、これは私の
最初のコンピュータービルドであり、ビルド
自体は
時々でも大丈夫でしたが
、OS El Capitanのインストールは
、間違ったコンポーネントの後で、Dante
のInfernoの上位レベルに好感が持てました。 インターネットの激しい
風やジョークが横ばいになって、AMD r9 390
を購入した特に貪欲なビルダーで
ある私は、1週間以上、
ボールダーを押して回避策を探して
いたので、モニターのオーディオを機能させる方法を見つけられませんでした。
外に出てスピーカーのペアを購入しました
マザーボードBluetoothが機能しなかっ
たので、外に出てUSBドングルを注文しました
Wi-Fiが完全にグレー表示されていた
ので、Amazonからイーサネットケーブルを注文し、
60ヘルツの問題で4kを解決しました
Final CutProのレンダリング時間は e
古い2012MacBookProよりもはるかに高速です。
この時点で
完全に無料で修理
されて
いたTLDRは、
マゾヒストであり、あなたがマゾヒストでない限り、TonyMac86の公式ビルドブログにあるパーツのみを使用します。  「実際に
は、nvmeハードドライブやPolarisグラフィックスカードなどの最新の部品に興味があり
ます。予想されるビルド時間まで10時間以上かかります。7時間
は燃える砂漠をさまよって
解決策を探し、3時間は欲求不満で
泣きます。
MacBook Proについてはまだ話し
ていませんが
、PC
マスターレースとAppleファンの両方に毎日のようにたくさんの弾薬があることを心配しないでください。
ナレーションを盛り上げるために、9か月間、ビデオを編集するビデオをアップロードします。ストーリー
が何であれ、そこに冗長なフレーズである補足ビジュアルを追加すると思いました。
ここでスタジオギブリの見積もりを右に移動
して、次のビットをリアルタイムで実行します。
最初に行うことは
、コンピューターの電源をオンにする
ことです。数秒後にBIOS
が起動し、クローバーが表示されます。
はいと言う
こと
ができるよう
に、メタのような方法でこのビットを配信すると、ちょっと面白く
て風変わりだと思ったので、私はまだスクリプトを読んでい
ます。 数秒後、ログイン
プロセスが開始され、
黒い画面になりますMac OSが起動し、
完全にログインしてい
ますが、グラフィックカードが
画面にデータを出力して
いないため、これは以前は発生していませんでした。
メジャー
セキュリティアップデートがリリースされ、画面
が真っ暗になり始めた後、
OSXとAppStoreを更新しました。最初に正しく表示するには、クローバーブートローダーでedidの挿入を無効にする
必要があるため、次に行う必要があります。 コンピューターを再起動し
て休憩します 芸術的で、今度は
自動起動を停止
してクローバーの状態を変更する必要があります。これにより、ログイン
しなくなり、オプションの
グラフィックインジェクターを必要とし、EDIDのインジェクトの選択を解除し
ます。このステップでは、USBキーボードを使用していることに注意してください。
メインのオペレーティングシステムにログインしていないので、Bluetoothキーボードではなく、
これを友人から永久に借り
ています。その冗談で
も大丈夫です。メインメニューに戻るインジェクトedidを無効にしました。
ここにあります。
これでうまくいくはず
です。2人のElCapitanにいます。しばらく
待って、Bluetoothが起動するかどうかを確認
します。コンピュータは
、Bluetoothデバイスの検索を開始します。また
、コンピュータの背面にBluetoothドングルを取り付けました。 さて、ここで
Bluetoothセットアップアシスタントに行きます。
ワイヤレスマウスやトラックパッド接続がありません
。見た目は見えます
が、
何も見つからないので、有線USBキーボードを使用します。つまり、
彼は死んだと思っていまし
た。  wei 彼はほとんどマスター
だったので、私は
合法的にこれを与えることができ
ますか？これは私が私のポップコーンのバターが好きではないことを知っているように私を商人にします私は
私のバターのポップコーンが好きな
ので私たちは ついに再ログインし
、約10分で
動作しました。この時点で稼働しているので、Bluetoothを壊すことが
多いUSBデバイスをあまり使用しない限り、申し訳ありませんが、何
でもできます。 映画やiTunesやAmazonが機能し
ない多くのウェブカメラストリーミング
サービスが機能しない本当に良いもの
も電源がクリックする私
はコンピュータを眠ることができないか、ディスプレイ
がオンに戻らないこれは普遍的です
ほとんどの
人がhackintoshを構築するときに使用するAMDグラフィックカードの問題は
、Final Cut Pro向けに非常に優れており、最適化されている
ため、仕事に最適なハードウェア
がコンピューターの基本的な機能を壊して
しまうため
です。 レンダリング時間を待っています
sコンピューターの醸造セックススコアは14
秒です。これは基本的にソニック
ザヘッジホッグとPFフライヤーズの速さです。
彼がPFフライヤーズを着ていた幸運な風のように走った火山で何かがおかしいのです。
アクションシュートは
この真新しいバラーの3倍の速さでした。  MacBook Proです
が、通常のワークフローと同じようにMac Final Cut Proを使用すると
、違いはそれほど大きくありません。たとえば
、このコンピューターで5分間のProResクリップに多くを適用する
と、1分ほどかかります。
このコンピュータでは22秒かかります。2
分30秒かかるので、平均
的な妥当なレンダリング時間の場合、hackintoshは
新しいMacBook Proの約2倍の速さです。
いいえ、妥当なレンダリング時間とは言えません。
YouTubeは
、このように見えます。
皆さん、新しいコンピュータのレンダリング機能をテストしてください
。8kフッテージの4つの異なるストリームを準備
し、
1つのウィンドウに凝縮しました。各ストリームには5つの異なるストリームがあり
ます。 今はたくさん適用されて
いますこれを簡単にしたくなかったので、
12Kの画面記録をオンに
してChromeで3つのYouTubeビデオを開きまし
た。CPUの温度がどのようなものか見てみましょう。
少し高いことがわかります。
同じ5分のクリップProResクリップを
使用してそれをh.264に変換すると、エクスポート時間がうまくいくと
思っていたよりも、新しいmacbookが4分10秒で処理することがわかり
ます。
50秒でこれは現実に
なりましたこれはもう少しでこれをすばやく同期することと関係があると思います最後に私が到達
する予定のハッキントッシュで見ることができるように、コンピューターを使用して毎日何回歯を磨くか
私のモルの下部の根はMacBookProでうまく機能している
ので、外側のエナメルさえも削り取るという兆候はないので、
このコンピューターはこれよりも速くレンダリングされますが、これはより
速くエクスポートさ
れ、自分自身を殺したくはありません
ユーザーが作成した可能性が最も高いエクスポート時間の違い ed問題はい私
はこれを何度も理解しようとし
ましたかはい私はこれまでに進歩を遂げましたか
いいえこの質問の行は
満足のいくパンチラインを持っていますいいえ
急速なQ＆AにNvidia
カードを使用して睡眠を修正しませんか/ ウェイクの問題
は、AMDハードウェア用に最適化されたFinal Cut Proではかなり遅くなるためです
。TitanとのTitan取引を購入したのとほぼ同じように
、Bluetoothの問題を解決するために公式のAppleBluetoothカードを購入しないの
は非常に高価だからです。 インストールする
ということは、基本的にコンピューターを分解することを意味
します。お金を節約するためにこのコンピューターを購入しました。
私はすでに非常に深く
、問題のほとんどが起動プロセスに起因する場合は、コンピューターをオンにする必要はありません。
空気の流れがあまり良くないので
、コンポーネント
を不必要な量の熱や
ほこりにさらしたくないです。
不必要なファンのノイズや高額な電気
料金にさらされたくないです。
長いプロジェクトが終わったときにコンピューターの電源を切ることができる
ので、個人的なワークフローに関しては、この新しい
MacBookProよりもhackintoshの方がレンダリングがはるかに優れていることがわかりました。
私が正しく対処しなければならないすべての回避策の
ために、このマシンにWindowsをインストールし、プレミアでエディターをインストールするだけです。そう
、MacBook Proに私たちを連れて来る雌犬ではありません。
まず、ビルドの品質と
美学は驚くべきものです。これは
主観的な嫌悪感です。 嫌い
なプレイは素晴らしい画面を再生します
ダイナミックレンジが改善されたので、肌の
トーンがさらにリアルに見えます
信じられないほどのスピーカーも大人の
メディア消費に適していますタッチバーは素晴らしいですフルスクリーンを離れる
ことなくpg-13ビットをスキップでき
ます 多くの
人がポートの不足について不満を言ってい
ますが、とにかくハッキントッシュでUSB SDカードリーダーを使用した
ので、キーボードにとってはちょっとしたポイントなので、これも少し極性があり
ますb  ut私は
AppleにRGB照明が含まれていないことを認めなければなりません、
そしてそれは明らか
に多くの人々がバッテリー
寿命の問題を経験しているということですが、私は今日早く
バスルームで30分のストリーミングセッションを行い、
92％のバッテリー寿命を残しました
あなたがたの
Vaselineが
2つのきれいなベビーワイプの
結論
でユニボディから非常に簡単に外れる場合、それはスターバックスでの私のヒップスターセッションに耐えることができると確信し
ています。 ゲーマーや従来の
コンピューターの専門家は、Gワイプを最小限に抑え
、
基本的なHTMLよりも少し
多くすること
を好みます。また、Nvidiaの10シリーズカードを使用してThe Witcher 3で取得できるフレーム数は、3分の1でした。
-私がそれについて考えるのをやめさせるコンピュータの能力を最も気にかけているレートライター
私はこのマシンをお勧め
しますが、それについてのレビューをすることから
別の冗長な結論を行使します
e
いじくり
回したいので、サポートされているパーツからPCまたはハッキントッシュを構築したい
場合は不安です。サポートしていない
人が嫌いな場合は、私のような時期尚早のはげを経験することになります。  Appleは
、
コンピューターがそれほど薄くなければ、
このビデオのように皮肉なコメントを残し
、スターバックスと
1月の不安とエチオピアの
クローバーのローストでたむろするのが好きなら、CPU温度をはるかに高くすることができるからです。 次に、このビデオにコメントを残して、
あなたのビーニーにDMを付けて、ハイタッチをしてください。
11月以降、私たちは
抑圧された少数派になり
ました。 私はお金を取りません
[音楽]